[Inaudible].
Sylvania is the Transylvania of America. Just as in the land of count, Dracula,
Pennsylvania has some incredible forests.
It is also cold and could well be the scene of one of the worst nightmares for
at least one American president Donald Trump. Right now,
we are going to explain why that is.
[Inaudible].
Remember that American voters do not decide to directly which president they
want, but choose the composition of the electoral college.
The electoral college is made up of 538 voters.
The distribution of electoral college members is more or less according to the
population of each state.
And this is where Pennsylvania becomes very important because we're talking
about the fifth most populous state in the United States.
[Inaudible].
So in Pennsylvania, there are no less than 20 Electra seats at stake.
There are many States that traditionally vote for the same party,
but there are also States where victory is more closely contested.
They are the so-called swing States and Pennsylvania is one of them in 2016.
Trump won this state, but in 2020, it is not clear what will happen.
There are even polls that are very favorable to Biden.
They indicate that Pennsylvania could be instrumental in bringing about a change
of tenant in the white house.
So what may happen in States like Pennsylvania has prompted headlines.
Yes.
Commit to accepting election results, Forbes.
And now I'm sure you're all wondering,
but what is the problem that Donald Trump only trusts that the elections are
cleaned when he wins?
Why does Trump say that he doesn't trust the election results? Well,
the explanation basically comes down to postal voting.
Keep in mind that in us elections in all but two States,
the party that gets the most votes interstate takes all its representatives in
the electoral college.
It doesn't matter if a candidate wins the election by one vote or by a million.
The most important thing is to
A lot of attention is paid to Pennsylvania because although 20 electoral votes
may not seem like much to you keep in mind that along with Florida,
Pennsylvania is the swing state that puts the most folks into play. And in 2016,
it was a matter of just 44,000 folks in a state of almost 13 million people
that were enough to make all 20 of those electors fall on Trump's side,
even though the difference was only seven tenths of a percent.
And of course what Trump won by a narrow margin.
He could also lose by a narrow margin. Now those 20 electors could.
Beef or Biden.
You lose sight of the fact that we're talking about 20 votes,
that one candidate wins and 20 votes that the other candidate fails to win.
Four years ago,
77 electoral college votes separated Trump and Clinton from these figures.
Pennsylvania represents
Halfway to the Democrats turn around. That's why Trump is so concerned.
This is an election where every detail could make a difference.
It was a mail-in ballots.
2020 will be the most rigged election in our nation's history.
Unless this stupidity is ended.
We voted during world war II and world war two, no problem.
But now they're using COVID in order to cheat by using Malins Donald Trump.
Just around the corner. The question is why is voting by mail so scary to Trump?
How might it affect States like Pennsylvania, more importantly,
how do Pennsylvanians view this election today on visual politics?
We're going to answer all of these questions, but first let's take a look here.
So history, sleepy,
Joe.
Rides through Pittsburgh, they are.
A few places that you can feel as close to the history of the United States.
As you do in pencil.
Pennsylvania.
It's a state where Philadelphia is located and it was in the city that in the
18th century, the independence of the United States was.
This.
Ring, the Liberty bell in the independence hall,
a bell that you can still visit today.
During the.
Civil war in the 19th century,
Pennsylvania was the scene of one of the most decisive battle.
The battle of Gettysburg.
And during the 20th century,
Pittsburgh steel was the material from which new York's great skyscrapers like
the empire state building were made. So basically Pennsylvania is rich.
With American history. In fact.
Friends to talk about steel is to talk about the high point in Pennsylvania's
economy.
The steel industry was the state's main industry along with coal mining.
But I think that you will agree with me that these are industries that have been
losing important since world war two. And since then,
new ways of generating energy have displaced coal. Meanwhile,
steel has been imported from Asian countries, such as China. However,
in many cases,
this means taking advantage of unfair competition or even dumping.
I think it's a commercial practice that consists of selling a product below its
normal price, or even below its cost of production.
In order to eliminate competitors take over the market,
a very risky tactic for a private company,
but within reach of Chinese companies,
which are strongly supported by the state.
Therefore many industries in Pennsylvania have been slowly.
Losing their doors. Pennsylvania.
Was once a very important to the U S economy,
but for several decades now its influence has been declining today.
We find a state without major cities, beyond Philadelphia or Pittsburgh.
27% of the population is rural while throughout the rest of the United States.
The average is 19%. So many of the steel mills are gone,
but Pennsylvanians still have their farms
As a state in which the primary sector also plays a very important role.
They are one of the largest producers of mushrooms.
Apples, and very products. Of course,
right now you're asking.
So given the state of affairs, what party do Pennsylvanians usually vote for?
Well, as I mentioned before,
Pennsylvania is a swing state and things are usually pretty close,
but we could say that in the last few decades,
it has been a democratic state since 1988 to Pennsylvania and has voted for the
democratic party presidential candidates six times,
Moreover its current governor Tom Wolf is from the democratic party.
He took office in 2014 and is pretty popular. That's why,
what happened four years ago was such a surprise.
Pennsylvania's 20 electoral college voters went to Donald Trump,
the anti-globalization speech and America first message actually worked many
people, including many Pennsylvania voted for Trump to do just that.
[Inaudible].
Donald Trump to slap 25% tariff on steel imports. Financial times.
That was the beginning of the cascade of tariffs that brought about the trade
war with China. And now that Trump's first term is over it's time to take.
[Inaudible].
2001 Pennsylvania steel industry employed 54,000 workers.
George Bush's presidency ended with 24% fewer jobs as a result of the great
recession and Chinese dumping.
Obama's eight years in office did not improve things much employment in the
secretary fell another 18% in contrast the data with Trump has improved
somewhat employment in Pennsylvania steel mills Rose 4%.
[Inaudible].
Of course the industry has far from recovered,
but at least Trump has managed to stop the trend.
So basically we could say that Pennsylvania is one of the States that has gained
from Trump's policies and yes, it's true.
Many other States and many other industries have been hurt by steel tariffs,
but we have to recognize one thing.
Donald Trump has created a trend around the world. Listen.
[Inaudible].
Canada's Trudeau hits China for dumping steel on global markets
business inquire.
You extends anti-dumping duties on Chinese steel you're at.
So we agree that Trump has made the correct call.
However he possibly overdid it and his solutions were not the most appropriate.
It is one thing to take a series of targeted measures in particular sectors,
but it is quite another to launch an entire trade war.
The exchange of Paris between China and the United States has made it difficult
for Pennsylvania and companies to sell abroad and has increased their costs.
And this is the downside of protectionism. Yes. In the short term,
steel exporters have regained some of the market they lost,
but other industries are paying the price.
Trump tariffs costs Pennsylvania more than $700 million in
2019. WITF.
This cost increase has spread to many sectors of the economy in this state.
Also the agricultural sector, still Trump is not planning to back down.
This is his policy and America first is what makes him different from previous
white house tenants. It also serves to appeal to good Patriots.
That's why he says China would rather sit down and negotiate trade agreements
with Biden. Then with him.
They'd say it is sleepy, Joe, sir, just sign right there.
Okay.
We've been losing hundreds of billions of dollars a year to China.
That's the stop. They understand that.
Trump has taken the steps. People expected him to take,
but the result isn't quite what they expected.
So his worst nightmares are about to come true this year, 2020,
it's a horror movie for Trump. Let's take a closer look.
Right now.
[Inaudible] to the COVID vampire.
Is there anything worse than being in Transylvania, surrounded by vampires? Yes.
Yes. There is that besides sucking your blood, you get the coronavirus
In the United States.
There have already been 220,000 deaths from coronavirus and more than 8 million
infections,
Pennsylvania rates eight for the state with the most deaths by COVID-19 more
than 8,500 infections already surpass 180,000.
There is a particularly serious circumstance in Pennsylvania.
It ranks four from the list of States with the oldest population in the country.
It was also one of the places most effected at the beginning of the pandemic.
The only reason the numbers aren't worse is because they don't have large
metropolises other than Philadelphia and Pittsburgh.
Pennsylvania's governor moderate Democrats,
Tom Wolf took confinement measures for some counties in mid-March before
extending them to all of Pennsylvania.
The deescalation was also County by County and in different phases that lasted
until early June. Was there an alternative? Well in may,
there was at least one man who fought.
[Inaudible].
People of Pennsylvania want their freedom now and are fully aware of what that
entails. The Democrats are moving slowly across America for political purposes.
They would wait until November 3rd. If we were up to them, don't play politics.
You're safe. Move quickly. Donald Trump.
Here is one more example of how tight the presidential elections are going to
be. As you can imagine,
the incidence of the coronavirus in Pennsylvania was concentrated,
especially in the beginning in Philadelphia,
Philadelphia County massively supports the Democrats. Four years ago,
Hillary Clinton got 82% of the vote that was almost half a million votes,
more than Trump. They brutal figure in Pittsburgh. The Democrats also won,
but the fight was more balanced
In contrast.
Rural Pennsylvania is closer to the Republican party and is emerging relatively
unscaved from the pandemic.
So you can get an idea of who supported president Trump's calls to end for
quarantine in Pennsylvania. President Trump is recovering from the Korea.
Virus. And so is America.
Even major protests against social distancing. What's more,
the Republicans controlled the state legislature and tightened the court on
deescalation so much that they forced the governor to use his veto power.
Governor Vito's bills to allow counties,
various industries to reopen WJ act.
We therefore find an even more polarized electorate in Pennsylvania than we did
four years ago.
The divide has widened between the urban pro Democrat send supporters of
restrictive measures to contain the virus and the rural pro Republicans who
believe that governor Wolf's measures have stifled the state's economy and its
businesses. The infection of Trump, his wife,
his son and half the white house has certainly been a blow to Republican
aspirations.
We no longer need any further proof that the Corona virus is rampant in the
United States.
This is not to say that we are much better off in the rest of the world,
but understand that the American voter cares about his or her own.
So in Pennsylvania,
the Republicans have looked for other issues to hurt the Democrats with.
And another issue they think they could take advantage of is.
[Inaudible].
Is a hydrocarbon extraction technique that consists of injecting a special fluid
at high pressure into the subsoil to break up the rock and extract the gas or
the oil.
It requires the use of more expensive technology than that used in conventional
energy fields.
The high price that crude oil reached in the last 15 years made fracking viable
the subject of a whole energy revolution in the United States.
Since then Pennsylvania has become the second largest natural gas producing
state in the United States. Only behind Texas.
[Inaudible].
Trump has tried to use the Democrats opposition to fracking,
to gain support in the areas surrounding Pittsburgh and Biden has had to hold
the greenest faction of the democratic party, uh, hopes to end fracking.
He knows that announcing such a measure could end his chances of winning over
Pennsylvania voters. But then again,
he did choose Senator Kamala Harris as his running mate.
And I assure you that Pennsylvanians have good memories.
Here is Kamala Harris in September, 2019.
There's no question I'm in favor of banning fracking. Yeah.
You heard it yourself. Kamala Harris, herself,
future vice president of the United States. If Biden wins and possibly more,
if anything else happens in the near future, she knows where she stands.
She is in favor of banning fracking.
So it's clear this election in Pennsylvania is going to be very, very close.
Who knows if it will be decisive,
but now let's talk about something that could make one or the other candidate
win.
Nightmare on Pennsylvania Avenue.
You now know that Donald Jr and Ivanka Trump,
we're not afraid of the terrifying characters of the eighties like Freddy
Krueger. No, their nightmares were played by the boogeyman,
but the boogeyman who brings them back,
Why the United States little is being said about this issue.
And it is possible that from November 4th onwards,
little else will be talked about at stake would be the person who gets to reside
at 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue in Washington.
And of course you can think about whether at this point in the film,
voting by mail is really such an important issue.
Well remembered that it's 2020 and anything is possible.
2020 has changed the rules of social behavior.
It's so many areas and also electoral base.
[Inaudible].
Iris is in the streets and there are many people who would prefer to avoid
crowded places like public relations States have had to rush through new methods
of voting because some did not contemplate the possibility of voting before
election day, without a justified reason.
It is expected that in this election mail-in voting will skyrocket because
people are afraid. And of course in California,
we're not talking about a handful of votes, but in the swing States,
it could be crucial. That may be the case in Pennsylvania,
traditionally for a vote by mail to be valid in the United States.
It had to arrive at the County elections office on election day.
At the latest in August,
the us postal service itself warned Pennsylvania ins that the backlog in their
offices could cause their votes not to be counted if they did not vote more than
15 days before the election,
all this has culminated in a new dispute between Republicans and Democrats that
has ended up in.
Pennsylvania Supreme court sides with Democrats extends mail-in ballot deadlines
to three days after election day, AP news.
This way,
Pennsylvania will consider the votes that arrive at the electoral office as good
until three days after November.
Third Republicans have appealed this decision at the federal level to the
Supreme court.
But hold on a minute because the fights between Republicans and Democrats have
only just begun Republicans,
believe the conditions are in place for the electoral fraud of the century.
They've also called for ballots to be rendered invalid for voters whose
signatures are not accurately identified with the officially registered one or
that voting by mail directly through a mailbox, not to be allowed.
Everything is in the hands of the courts.
And the worst thing is that in other States like Ohio or Texas,
the story is similar, uh, chaos off gigantic proportions.
But to understand what is happening, you have to take a look.
Look at this.
This poll conducted by the center for opinion, research in Pennsylvania,
more than half of Democrats plan to vote by mail while only 10% of the
Republicans plan to do so. In 2016,
there were 300,000 mail ballots in Pennsylvania. This year,
that number will probably increase five or six fold.
Bring the total closer to 2 million votes.
This is when it pays to remember that in 2016,
the elections in the state were decided by a ridiculous margin of folks.
Trump had 44,000 more votes than Hillary Clinton.
And I'll give you another fact before the postal vote was counted.
Republican margin was only 20,000 votes higher. Where am I going with all this?
Well, I want to get to the point that election night promises strong emotion.
[Inaudible].
It is certain that the count in Pennsylvania will begin in favor of Donald
Trump. Thanks to the count in rural areas, which is faster than in the cities.
In addition,
there are predictions from the economist that even we've up to 70% progress in
the mail ballot counts, Pennsylvania may still hold onto a Republican victory.
And here we have two scenarios.
Imagine that those 20 electoral college votes at stake in the end of the
decisive ones,
how would Donald Trump view his shift from a Republican Pennsylvania to a
democratic Pennsylvania?
[Inaudible].
Furthermore, I'm not talking about a last minute change,
but rather after counting all the votes that have arrived by Friday,
November 6th, I can imagine you all on Twitter, just constantly pressing F five.
Then there is the other alternative. If things are very tight,
it could be that if a figure as low as 3% of the postal votes were not counted
because they arrived late or if they were not considered valid,
for whatever reason, the balance would fall one way or.
[Inaudible].
So far absentee voting is Donald Trump's worst nightmare. After November 3rd,
it could be everyone's worst nightmare could something equally bad happened.
If Trump didn't accept the election results? Well, yes,
and they are already preparing us for it.
Biden says Chicago honoree at polls is the only way he could lose us
election. Roy.
It is likely that if there is no victory to one of the two contenders,
it will be a mess. Whatever happens.
We will be keeping you posted here on visual politic,
but now the questions are over to you.
Do you think we will have a final result on election day or will we have to
wait? Do you think the Pennsylvania results will be so close this time?
Furthermore, if you were from the state,
would you still be with Trump or would you bet on.
[Inaudible] if you want to learn more about politics and world affairs and
here's some more of my lovely voice, um,
check out the reconsidered podcast where we don't do the thinking for you find
reconsider@wwwdotreconsideredmedia.com or on Apple or Google play or your
favorite podcast.